if you don't know how great our next
guest is he'll be more than happy to
tell you if you don't like watching NFL
players celebrate you can probably blame
him because the whole generation of
athletes wanted to be just like him he
ran faster backwards than most people
run forwards and his outfit today is
probably worth more than all of the
tenets wardrobes combined
please welcome primetime the young
sender look clean prime is here it's
good to see again I didn't realize you
got prime time from a basketball game 36
how good were had a couple of dunks
back-to-back in my home he said you know
what man you primetime I said you're
right I was Allstate had all pers my
football coach later told me he hit all
my basketball offers but do you think
obviously football you're a Hall of Fame
hmm but if you just dedicated one to one
sport if you did baseball and just did
that do you think he would have been a
hall-of-famer
well a Hall of Fame is skewed now I
don't even know what all of Fame is how
can Barry Bonds not be a Hall of Fame I
don't hike and Roger Clemens not be a
Hall of Fame but before all the
accusations I think very Bonds had three
MVPs before you even start accusing him
anything how can he not be a dirt Hall
of Fame well I I could look at bonds and
say he accomplished enough I can't say
that with Roger Clemens
because Clemens went to Toronto the Red
Sox gave up on it true hey Roger Clemens
was still Roger Clemens faced Roger
Clemens
still Roger Clemens and then when it
comes to football what is the d'haran
Hall of Fame what is all the frame right
now is it a guy who played a long time
and what is so skewed now I don't know
what's what once upon a time a Hall of
Famer was somebody who changed the durn
game who who made you want to provoke
you to reach in your pocket and paper
admission to go see that guy play forget
the rest of the team you wanted to see
that guy that's not a Hall of Fame
anymore
everybody Tom Dick and Harry you're a
Hall of Famer you're a Hall of Famer
you're a Hall of friend he let everybody
in this thing not exclusive anymore and
I don't like it okay what would be your
definition know someone who changed the
game had a profound take and a profound
influence on the game Randy Moss all of
you like like you know you have to think
about that Barry Sanders you don't have
to think about it Eli Manning if you
have to think then not a hall-of-famer
if you have the big it shouldn't be you
shouldn't
how many think how many they allow in
every year not this year cuz this year's
like everybody come on in his everybody
come on in
he normally is what seven five or six
yeah why does it have to be it should be
based on are you that guy were you that
guy not just because we got to meet a
quota
it's Richard Sherman a hall-of-famer yes
a little pause to me yeah because it's
not complete I hate saying oh guys
they're not complete okay
I mean guys that I would have without a
doubt like Tom Brady that you don't have
to be complete he's that guy and I start
to wonder this and maybe it's not fair
asking you this but you brought up the
topic it's and I always say if I say
your name and then you have that
reaction right that's all right and
there are guys like Philip Rivers I
don't have that reaction that he's a
hall-of-famer
well I like really talking about those
guys that have played hard that are
still playing right now okay Thomas a
Hall of Famer I got up under the dough
okay because if I got to think about
okay in there another guy that just just
as good that paid more little dividends
than that that's not right yeah I hate
to beat up the Hall of Famer effect or
whatever that is that but I was happy
and enthused
but it's going all over the place now
man
how do we how do we pick out a defensive
back in your opinion and say he's a hold
of someone had a profound impact on the
game that really shut down the game that
that you were afraid to deal with you
know that we're gonna be consequences
it read those type of guys
Darrelle Revis yes those type of guys
but running back it seems like it's hard
to like Frank Gore Hall of Famer who
Frank Gore yes but I would have to say
longevity okay longevity yeah and at
that position what yes yeah break doors
oh my god yes but see some guys you say
I'm gonna preface it because I'm
thinking about well this other guy got
in like when you say he like and say
well it's quarterback guy Dean why not
Eli like I could fight for him or didn't
I say well how did that guy get in I
don't want to be the guy to say I don't
want to be the gatekeeper yeah you know
how did you get in here I don't want to
be that guy who was the quarterback that
maybe figured you out a little bit
better than he nobody figured me out
anybody make you nervous it was a great
quarterback like you I played an era man
my era was different because not only
did we have the great quarterback he had
a great receiver like when you played
against Joe Montana you had to deal with
Jerry not only the best receiver but
they had a turn quarterback when you
dealt with Troy Aikman you had to deal
with Mike Urban this guy had a you know
the same thing in Buffalo what what they
had would read I mean often yes
everybody had a really good quarterback
and that constituted mass shoot you get
one step the court of the ball is gonna
be there isn't it really not like that
right now that that Batman don't have a
Robin and that's tough for those guys
but you got mahomes who feels like
there's something special to him but yes
also got a great play caller and Andy
Reid he's got Kelsey and he's got Tyree
care yeah but that's not you're saying
he would be that without them
like mahomes is the kind of kid that
would be great without all of that maybe
not as great but he would be great
and we keep we got to go back and forth
know who's really called in the place
cuz we got ignore Eric P enemy yeah we
got to give the man his credit that's
why you're not gonna get a darn job
because we always say in his other guy
calling the plays but every time I look
at the game he's gone to the place I
didn't did he get interviewed okay once
does he not have enough experience at
that position how how can you not have
enough experience no offensive
coordinator I think it's not just
experience I think is the timing of it
in the likability do they want you to be
the face as the head coach of that
franchise yeah yeah you were gonna did
you really want to coach Florida State
yes I'm gonna be the head coach of
college football next year we're
somewhere I'm that definite I'm that I'm
not assured that I am
why did Florida State not work out
several reasons it got interesting it
was interesting I got time
it was another school as well that we
went that second interview and this is a
desire this is something that is my
calling I'm gonna coach college football
head coach not coach head coach do you
have a deal in place right now no I'm
not gonna say that but I'm gonna be a
coach but do you know where no okay but
you're open to going good nowhere but I
am
but I'm open I'm open
yes it has it fit me I have to fit them
they had to understand I come with some
some stuff I come with not luggage but I
come with I want to win I want to do it
a certain way
what if they you called would you you
know what it's so funny because I saw
that when I was watching on television
my son is a phenomenal quarterback my
youngest son you know as the plethora of
offers we're going to visit the you
Saturday
but would you coach the you you never if
you could why not are you a package deal
with your son no I've never been a
package deal with anybody
[Applause]
[Laughter]
deals but never not together son I'm
intrigued with with this as a head coach
yeah damn what kind of offense you're
gonna run a wide open wide open offense
but versatile versatility get the ball
in the hands of the playmakers that's my
philosophy but not just our peels but
everything you see in college I mean you
gotta understand the person that you
have and run off is based on what you
have at hand do you want a coach and
cold weather okay yeah I want a coach
period I don't think your own socks do
you excuse me you don't own socks yes I
do you do yeah I'm just not wearing at
the Dickens in that fashion when I'm in
Miami oh that doesn't look good
[Laughter]
like stuff up there I know to make you
look better thank you
what do you think of this shirt here you
look good though it's different do you
gotta take this black jacket off the
back of your chair though is that it's
not good it's not good it contrasts you
like you're undecided on what you want
to do yeah yeah all right got it off
there yeah there we go a little bit more
there you go I've been looking at now is
know what contrast and now is better
yeah yeah I like it
what's your big question going into this
game no no Sunday my big question going
to this game is are both quarterbacks
gonna be who they supposed to be
everybody you figured my Holmes is gonna
be my Holmes so you're really question
is this Garoppolo it's gonna be the guy
if he has to be the guy instead of
handing the ball off I think he could I
think he has intangibles to be the guy
they have several receivers and a tidy
and out of this nerd world this is one
of the most evenly matched Super Bowls
we've seen in quite some time I'm really
excited for this game I cannot wait to
see how it unfolds do you make a
prediction not yet but you will yeah I
don't care who wins I like good football
yeah I just want good football that's
when people say who you're rooting for I
said I just want a great I want a good
football game I want everybody to be who
they supposed to be
I want Kelsey to be who he's supposed to
be he will kiddo
is gonna be who he's supposed to be both
quarterbacks I need them to be who
they're supposed to be both defenses I
know tying Matthew is gonna be that guy
Richard Sherman is gonna be that guy I
cannot wait to see how it on
now it goes down to the coordinators
who's gonna fold like what I'm trying to
say is in the game in the playoffs would
Baltimore you know versus Tennessee why
why can't we get a first down and we
failed on fourth fourth downs yeah and
you're running a play that you hadn't
run all year
I have never seen Lamar Jackson take the
snap and try to run off tackle where did
that play come from run the stuff that
is guiding you here that's when you see
somebody fold under pressure and I don't
think these coordinators are gonna fold
under pressure
Paulie took off his socks yeah that look
bad you know what I'm so proud of you
thank you Friday
I'm so damn proud of ya now what did you
do with your footage I got rid of them
there you go I'll get all mine you say
so proud you're a good man of your fifty
three interceptions yeah okay
did you did you ever get a quarterback
to sign of football I would never do
that I would never do that and I would
never take my jerries off and give you
to another man after the game I don't I
don't condone that I just played a game
against you and I wanted to just
dominate you
now we're gonna exchange jerseys pound I
understand it on the field after the
game by the way you can see prime after
us the Super Bowl 50 for broadcast on
NFL game k-prime and you can also ask
about Hall of Fame hair restorer hair
comm you see it I'm coming back player
with your hair yeah your hairline is
back it is I'm trying to get Rich Eisen
to come on in
I'm trying to I'm trying to get in the
come on in but I don't I don't know if
he want us to make the III I think he's
worried about you guys like what are you
gonna say no you look good I can help
you
Paulie cuz you yeah I can already help
you in one way I can help you a Deion's
makeover yeah so you could help Paulie
with his hair yeah because he has it you
know how hard it is to get black hair
back no it's very tough you guys can get
it back in a heartbeat I mean it's tough
what you find black hair you know but
you take it off the sides and they plant
it in the top and it grows that's the
formula that's what happens and how he
never stops growing on the sides of your
head God plays their funny trick on us
like why are you just right there you
want to play that game with us I can
help you or also you'll see the guy
who's got a full beard and then he's
bald Danny's bow like I usually the guy
got a bag full of hair on my shoulders
restore hair calm you can look just like
Dion says yeah what are the same smell
you can't get that it's great to see you
Prime thank you thank you
the grills yes always plug the grills
the Trager girls let me tell you some
man they're blessing to the Sanders home
thank you when we sent that to you and
then you got that then you had a big
party soon we really use it oh and we
got Chad we brought chat in to make
lunch for us this week so he's prime
time you can see him after the game on
NFL Network for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV streamed for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]